[Music]
all right let's go to kerry in charlotte
north carolina what's up carrie how are
you doing
hi dr john i'm doing okay how are you
outstanding what's going on how can i
help
um so basically my parents are in their
late 60s
um they do not have a will or any
savings or
any end of life plan set up and they're
not willing to talk about it
oh gosh
that's the word why why
um so growing up not a lot was talked
about in our family including finances
um actually in 2018 my dad received a
huge inheritance which has been would
have been enough
for them to have a good bit of savings
and by the grace of god my parents
bought the house that's fully paid for
my dad also bought a newer car
beyond that we don't know if they have
paid off any credit
card debts or not however i know for
certain that my dad donated the rest
of their inheritance money or i guess
his inheritance money he's the one that
received it
um to their church and when my siblings
and i
found this out we unanimously decided
that we were not paying for
any care that they may need in the
future because we don't feel that we
should be
responsible for their financial
carelessness
my siblings and i are huge supporters of
you and dave ramsey so about a year ago
we attempted to talk to them about their
will and any end-of-life plans that they
may have
and we got shut down instantly now we
want to attempt to talk to them again
because we don't want to be blindsided
in the end but we recently discovered
that my dad has a borderline personality
disorder
and we aren't sure the best way to
approach this conversation because we
aren't sure which side of my dad we're
going to get
when we do
yeah that's hard so here's the first
thing i don't care about the diagnosis
just throw that out okay um don't
don't dance around that um a 60 plus
70 year old person that either thinks
they're diagnosed with borderline or
husband
like man we're we're past that um
the reality is um and by the way you and
your brothers and sisters
you all got together i applaud your
unity way to go man
i know a lot of adult kids that are like
whatever what y'all decided to do
is kind of dumb and reality isn't going
to play out
you're not going to let your parents
just sit on the street and be like well
we shouldn't have given it to church
you're going to drive off in your car
that's not how that will play out but i
do applaud y'all at least talking about
this amongst
your siblings okay um i know it feels
good to be like we'll show them
that same will show them attitude is the
same attitude your parents
taught you yeah which is the oh yeah
we're not talking about
it's the same like and so what i would
tell you is as an adult how old are you
i'm 27. yeah so you're an adult and
there's a really crummy moment when
kids suddenly find themselves parenting
their adult
parents which is what you're doing right
um and this is super frustrating and
super annoying
um i know a few folks in my life that
will not have this conversation
as a guy who has been around death for
so long i don't understand it
um and as a guy who's lost friends
who left their spouses with a lot um
with life insurance or the will
i it doesn't make any sense to me at all
i've also learned over over the years
that talking about death
and talking about finances is such a
shame inducing scary
um fear proposition that some people
don't have the emotional
or spiritual or mental tools to deal
with it
now they don't get a pass i don't care
if you have the tools you got to deal
with it because it's going to deal with
you
right yes 100 of us don't get out of
this thing
right um the way my buddies john king i
love
he's one of my best friends on the
planet and i love the way he says it he
says the only reason to not have a will
is if you hate your wife and kids that's
it and so if you hate your wife and kids
keep plugging along without a will um
if you do here's the reality you're
if you do love your wife and kids if you
do love your husband if you do love
america if you love your church whatever
yeah
i know and i know i'm preaching the
choir here you gotta get real you have
to
you have to it's not it's not a debate
if you have a dog where's your dog gonna
go
where's your pet gonna go for credit
loud right right
so the only recommendation i have for
you is this
number one don't go to war over your
parents
okay okay at some point you're gonna
poison yourself hoping that they're
gonna
they're gonna die right you are gonna
get yourself
so fired up and worked up and your
brothers and sisters every time you'll
get together
it's gonna be i can't believe how stupid
mom and dad are they're so dumb they're
so this and that
and you are gonna just create a bed of
resentment and anger towards your
parents that's not gonna do anybody any
good
it's not gonna make a will materialize
right so you're gonna be deciding
to shorten your life over an issue you
can't control
right right um and i know that's
maddening and i know it's frustrating
there is a moment when one of you and
it'd be awesome if it's you
um calls them or y'all all get together
and you say i know we all said we're not
going to help them the reality is we're
not going to let them starve to death on
the side of the road
and we they are going to sell their
house because that's gonna be the only
equity they have it's gonna be the only
money they have they're gonna move in
with one of us
or some of us or they're gonna move into
a one-bedroom apartment and that
money that equity is gonna pay down that
apartment until they pass away like
those are the financial realities that's
the math problem they're going to be
facing
um and just saying we're not going to do
anything again it feels good but it's
not reality
and then here's the last ditch effort um
i'm going to do this
i'm going to give you a free will the
same will that i use okay
it's i use it with mama bear wheels
we've got a ramsay's got a partnership
with them
um if you hang on the line i'm gonna
send you a code so that you can give
them a free will
okay right they may not use it they may
um
they may take the paper of the letter
you write it on and use it as two ply
that's their choice
right you can say i know uh we did the
best we could
and i want you and your brothers and
sisters i want one of y'all to draft a
letter
um it'd be best if you hand wrote it but
you can type it up it's great
have everybody read it everybody sign
off on it and then this
may take a week or two i want you to
hand mail it to everybody if you don't
live in the same town
i want everyone to sign it and i want it
to be a love letter
not a demand letter okay okay
i want it to be a letter that says you
guys are growing up mom and dad y'all
raised us to think about the future
you raised us to think about um our
legacy
we're so grateful for the the stuff
y'all did give us
now my gut tells me there's a lot of
crap
back there that you if you wanted to
write a letter to them
and let them have it it'd be a 40 or 50
page letter am i right
yeah yeah you're right yes growing up in
the house of somebody borderline
personality store that won't deal with
it
um the will is just the tip of the
iceberg right you've been dealing with
this crap forever
okay i know this leveler will be hard
um your goal is not to punish your
parents you can't do that for them
your goal is to say hey i want you guys
to have end of life care
one year my parents surprised me and my
brothers i met my brother and sister and
i
they gave us for christmas long-term
care insurance right
they weren't wealthy growing up they
weren't um my parents didn't have they
didn't have a lot they worked their
butts off and they're incredible people
they didn't have a lot so they bought
long-term care insurance
and um it was a palpable relief
we all exhaled whoo it was pretty
awesome
um so all it says who knows that that
may happen
you can take this call and send it to
him if you think that will help
um maybe sometimes hearing from another
person but at the end of the day
going to war against your family is just
going to leave a pile of bodies and
nobody's going to win
and you're not going to get that will
and you're not going to get
that resolution that you want so you and
your brothers and sisters write them a
love letter
tell them hey y'all got him a code they
don't have to tell them that this was
free unless they watch this show then
you're busted
um and we got you will they can do it on
the computer together
tell them that one of y'all will fly out
with them and um
tell them you're willing to donate
everything they have to the church or
whatever that you just want them to have
a plan okay right and you guys are gonna
have to get over this
your dad got an inheritance he did what
he wanted to with his money
could that have been yells yes could it
have helped you guys out yes could have
helped him out yes
it didn't so let it go right right that
bitterness and resentment
just keeps you awake at night it doesn't
bring that money back
it goes back to those things you can't
control that and so i'm not gonna spend
one second of energy on things i can't
control and when i feel myself trying to
control things that are outside of my
scope
i'm either going to call a friend i'm
going to write it down and let it out
man i'm going to let it go
and i'll say this again and i was a
smart aleck last time i'll say it
i'll i'll say it gent more gently er is
that a word
that is that a word medicine gently here
i don't think so i think
i just embarrassed myself um luckily
there's only 14 and a half listeners on
this
and i said half one of you all is just
like doing something not even paying
attention so you're a half a listener
here's the deal you have to have a will
you
got to have a will the mama bear wheels
are not expensive
like they're less than 100 bucks right
you have to
have a will if you're a college grad and
you just got out of school
get a will right um if you are a
grown-up get a will
if you are a young um 800 years old get
a will
you have to nobody wants a government
telling them what to do in their when
they're alive
god help you you want them taking care
of your money
and equity and family when you're dead
this is your one shot right to take care
of the people that you love
i know talking about death is hard it is
nobody wants to imagine life without us
here but the reality is 100 of us
don't get out of this thing alive and so
100 of us need to have a plan
i think the last i saw 70 or something
don't have a will
good folks i don't care if you don't
have any to get a will
and more importantly one of the most
blessed conversations i've had in my
lifetime
my dad called met with me
said hey here's my plan here's where the
will is here's where all the stuff is
um here's where this is gonna go so
we're gonna this is gonna go i want you
to bring your
you know this and that and that and this
what an awesome conversation to have
that's trust it's intimate it's
vulnerable it's my old man saying hey
i know i got a one-way ticket out of
this deal and me saying me too
and by the way i just got my life
insurance renewed and changed up
i sent my wife a copy obviously and i
sent a copy to my old man
just said just in case my wife is
sheila's grieving real hard
i want you to know where this is it's
just a common thing in our home and i
want to let everybody know if you're
scared to talk about it it just
brings your home peace and there is
there is no dragons that i know of
um and there is no correlation between
talking about death
writing up a will and then you actually
dying that's not how that works you
won't accelerate the process
it just lets you sleep a little bit
deeper
ah thank you so so much for that call
carrie you are awesome